[音楽]
みなさんこんにちは
7月7日は
七夕でしたねー
天の川の西と東に離れ離れになった織姫星と彦星が一年に一度だけ
であぶひ
ところが伝説によるとその日に雨が降って天ノ川の水かさが増すと2人は会うことが
できません
でもちょっと疑問に感じません
7月7日といえば中の真っ最中ですよ
なぜそんな日に七夕祭りをするんでしょう
そもそも七夕は奈良時代に中国から伝わってきて
平安時代に貴族の間で花開いた
その頃のカレンダーは
来院太陽暦
今で言う旧暦ですね
今のカレンダー対応暦とは約1カ月のズレがある
今のカレンダーでは
今年の旧暦の七夕は8月7日になります
その頃になれば次も開けて
織姫星も彦星も頭の鉄平
元気に輝いています
このように少し深読みするだけで謎が解けますよね
ところで皆さんは
七夕の夜織姫星と彦星が本当にくっつくと思います
そう思っていらっしゃる方はかなりのロマンティストです
織姫星と彦星と間の距離は16光年
仮に織姫星が1星に手を振ったとしますね
それに彦星が気がつくのは
なんと16年後
途方もない距離です
なので
七夕の夜に二人は出会うことはあり得ないですね
ところが江戸時代
この2つの星をくっつけて遊んでいたんですよ
どうやってって思いますよね
意外と簡単です
水を張った大きな ok
それを庭先に出して
そこに織姫と彦星を移します
そして波を起こすそうするとその波に乗って織姫星と彦星がくっつくように見えると
いうわけなんですね
江戸時代の人って
おしゃれて道満チックだと思いません
私はこのような天文学に関する話題を
歴史考古学
文学
哲学
音楽といった
様々な分野と融合させた講演活動をやっています
しかしそのように天文学を多角的に捉えるようになったのは
ある先生の一言があったからなんです
今から15年前のこと
私の天文学の主張である山田孝之先生
その先生からお前
プラネタリウムは何のためにあるか知っとるか
問われました
私は割と自信を持ってプランタリウムは満天の星空の下
解説を聞きながら
宇宙のことを楽しく勉強すればと答えたんです
すると山田先生は何ておっしゃったと思います
一般的には確かにそうかもしれないが本質は違う
プラネタリウムは
生きることの意味を考える空間だ
私が面食らいました
一体それどういう意味
その後ままと山田先生は星になってしまわれたため
その詳しい意味を聞くことはかないませんでした
その時から私は
遺言となったられたリウムは生きることの意義を考える空間だ
の答えを探し求めて長い旅に出ることになったのです
それまでの私の鋼材公演は
星座の探し方
流れ星の探査つの仕方
天体望遠鏡の使い方
天体写真の撮影の仕方といったハウトゥーものが中心だったんです
しかし
山田先生から良い子を受け取ってから少し変わりました
例えば皆さんは皆既日食を見たことありますか
月が太陽の前を通り過ぎて
完全に対応を隠すことによってその周りに幻想的な頃だがふわーっと広がる
珍しくてとても美しい現象です
この映像をご覧下さい
じゃないから
4日
[拍手]
ana ん
ああああああああ
はぁ
ああああああ
これ
ん
[拍手]
赤がみよう
[音楽]
黒ああああ
はぁ
私はこの皆既日食の仕組みとかいつどこで起こるか
そしてまたどうやったら写真撮れるかといったことを中心に
話をしてたんです
しかし融合を受け取ってからはその現象の本質を
考えるようになりました
皆既日食はなぜ
これマネー
人を魅了するのでしょうか
それは同じ大きさに見える太陽と月が
ピタリと重なることによって
非日常の世界が広がる
それを見た我々は畏敬の念をそこに感じるからなんです
もし月がとても小さかったらこのようなドラマティックな現象にはなりませんよね
実際
月の大きさは太陽の400分の1しかありません
それが同じ大きさに見えるのは地球からの距離がちょうど400倍違うからなんです
だから皆既日食がドラマティックな現象になるんですね
これは火星や近世からでは絶対に見ることはできません
以前から私たちに送られた軌跡です
このように皆既日食のことを少し深く知ることによって
俄然本物の解禁食を見たくなりませんか
さてへ
星座は今から5000年前にメソポタミアで生まれました
メソポタミアの人たちはどのような思いで星座を作ったんでしょう
ちょっと深読みしてみると
その一端をうかがい知ることができます
例えば秋の代表的な星座みずがめ座
水瓶座の周りには
うお座みなみのうお座くじら座
いるか座といった水に関係する星座がたくさん散りばめられているんです
これは偶然かなと思ったりしますが実はこんな理由があるのです
メソポタミアは砂漠同然の家
5ウキがやってくるかそれがとても重要だった
ある夜
星空を眺めていた件者は水瓶座ば明け方の東の空に昇ってくると
ウキがやってくることに気がついた
このことはできるだけたくさんの人たちに知らせなくてはいけない
分かるようにしなくてはいけない
という思いで水瓶座の周りに
水に関係するせいだを配置したというわけなんです
カレンダーなんて無かった時代
星座をカレンダーとして活用していたんですね
まさに経験から生まれた生活の知恵と言えるでしょう
こんな風に
好奇心と想像力を働かせて
観測や研究を続けていく時に私自身
知識を深読みすることが
前にも増して心地よく
楽しくなってきたんです
そして私の鋼材公園のないように奥行きと深みが生まれていきました
すると私の周りも変化が生じました
何と私の講座や講演の聴衆が増えたのです
特にシルバー世代の方が
それは
私の話を聞いぺー
くれた人たちが
ちょっと
物事を深読みすることを楽しいと感じてくれたんだと思います
このように
知的好奇心を震わせて想像力をたくましくし
物事を深く考え
それが生きることの意味を考えることだと感じ始めていた
2006年
プラネタリウムをボランティア組織で企画運営できないかという打診を受けました
私にとってみれば
雷タリウムは生きることと意味を考える空間だの答えを実践するまたとないチャンス
快くをキックしました
ボランティアを募集したところ本当にたくさんの方が集まってくれました
しかも年齢性別人生経験
生活環境がさまざま
それでいて皆
星や宇宙やプラ板リームが大好きな人たちばかり
最初に話し合ったことは
生きることの意味を考えるプラネタリウムをどういうふうに創り上げていくか
まず
満天の星空や天文現象は実際に見て五感で感じないと
その感動は湧いてこない
そしてそれを
ただ単に
美しい素晴らしいといった形容詞一言で
を得るのではなくてその裏に隠された
心の底から湧き上がってくる本当の意味での感動を掘り起こし
それを表現する
そのためには感性をいつも磨こうと
また
星座の成り立ち
星座神話に隠された深い意味
星の一生
宇宙の歴史
そういったことに絶えず興味を持ち
知的好奇心を膨らませ
想像力を育んでいこうと
また
実際のプラ板ルームの解説においては
単位
5室等案内や天文現象の紹介をするだけではなく
解説者一人ひとりが人生において経験したこと
考えたこと
感動したことを
織り交ぜながらより奥深く解説をしてい
そこに
語りかけるような話をしていこうと
満天の星空の下このような解説を聞いているときっと想像力が開いてきます
物事を深く考えるたびに
誘われていくことでしょう
これこそが
山田先生が残された
プラネタリウムは生きることの意味を考える空間だ
の答えなと
今私は確信しています
プラネタリウムをご覧になる多くの方々が
満天の星空に包まれて
好奇心と
想像力をたくましくして
生きることの意味を考え
一人一人が味わい人生を送られることを心から願っております
ありがとうございました
[拍手]